all right well I'm very excited to be
here this is my second time here at NDC
Minnesota last time I was here is
talking about typescript and react and
they those those technologies are going
to be featured in this talk but that is
not what this talk is focused on so with
that let me just briefly introduce
myself I'm Camryn Ayub this is a photo
of me in the South of France now I'm a
Minnesota native so this is my natural
habitat but I would love for this to be
my natural habitat this is Provence
France my wife and I if you want to know
a little bit more about me my wife and I
took a sabbatical about four years ago
and the original intention was that I
would work remotely well that didn't pan
out so instead my company offered a
six-month sabbatical no work so we lived
in France for six months and we traveled
around we went to Morocco and Amsterdam
and the UK and Oslo and all sorts of
other places it was truly like a
life-changing experience if you have the
opportunity to do a sabbatical I suggest
you do that we did it before we had kids
and is just like a transformative like
perspective change so after that my life
well my life had never been about work
but especially after that it's not going
to ever be about work it's about just
enjoying life with that said I do enjoy
the work that I do so I work for a local
retailer which will become very
apparently a parent but on the side I do
Pluralsight courses so I have two
courses on Microsoft Azure one course on
Raven DB if any of the if any of you V's
Raven DB and then I also manage and run
a website called keep track of my games
so I'm a gamer I was playing games
before I started this presentation I've
always been a gamer but I also have a
very terrible memory so if a game is
coming out and there's a release date
I'm not gonna remember when the game
comes out so I built an app that lets me
track those release dates it'll text me
on my phone or email me when games are
coming out and now it's evolved into
more of a video game organizational tool
so if you have a collection of video
games you can manage them through keep
my games on that same line my friend
started a game engine here in
Minneapolis and it was written in
typescript let's start about six years
ago and that's what those games I was
just playing are built-in and so we do
regular releases and so I'm a core
contributor on the excalibur Jas game
engine so check it out we try to make it
really easy to use so if you have young
kids and you want to get them into game
development it might be a gateway drug
does anyone listen to the podcast impact
theory okay if you want to be more
successful like personally and you want
to grow personally and you want to be
more successful in your career listen to
that podcast if you listen to that
podcast every day you are going to
radiate happiness and bring that into
everywhere everywhere that you go now
the host Tom Bilyeu talks about the idea
of a personal narrative this is the
story that you tell yourself and that
story would sound something like I'm the
kind of person that and so you should
finish that sentence for yourself and
this requires some reflection on what do
you what what statement would I say one
the one statement that would might
define everything that I do so for me
I'm the kind of person that seeks to
learn and seeks to solve problems now
originally I thought that it might be
loves to learn and loves to solve
problems but I changed it to seeks
because that is really what I like what
I really like doing seeking out problems
is just something that I enjoy doing I I
tried to I'm not happy when I'm not
solving problems I'm happiest when I'm
solving problems whether they're
business problems or technical problems
or personal problems that kind of stuff
now speaking of problems this last
project that I've been on at work for
the past year had a lot of challenges
and there was a lot of business
problem-solving going on and so that's
what I'm here to speak about today now I
could just explain what our application
does and how we architected it but I
need to show you the context of the
problem domain that we're in so I'm
going to paint you a picture but I'm a
terrible artist so rather than that I'm
just going to show you a picture
now you can guess maybe what company I
work for but if you go to our website
and you search for products I'm very
excited about Borderlands 3 are there
any gamers here in the audience yeah a
little bit so Borderlands 3 I'm very
excited about its coming out in
September but when you when you view
this product on our website there is a
bunch of data that gets displayed so
data like the product title the price
but more than that if you scroll down
there's a whole bunch of attributes
around these items that we collect and
we show to you so model compatibility ok
Borderlands is on ps4 it's also
available on Xbox one the street date
when it goes live is September 13th 2019
used to keep track of my games to keep
track of that but it gets more complex
that's an example video game any Game of
Thrones fans here spoiler alert
Dumbledore dies just kidding you can buy
came of Thrones shirts on our website
this is not an advertisement but it's
there if you want to there are totally
different attributes around a t-shirt so
I'm wearing a men's t-shirt it's made of
100% cotton it's below waist these are
not video game attributes these are
t-shirt attributes and even more than
that each of these sizes is our unique
items like we have a small size of
medium size a large size these are all
attributes that we have to keep track of
so the system that I work on is the
system that manages that data so how do
we manage that kind of data well we
manage it very carefully so as you can
imagine if I collect the wrong
information and it gets displayed on our
website someone is going to get a very
stern talking-to so our application
helps protect against that so one of the
primary goals of our application is to
make sure that users don't enter bad
data so it has a very strong data
quality focus and because of that it has
a very strong user experience focus and
we have dedicated UX designers on our
line of business application and that
was pretty unique for me
and that was that was pretty fun now I
work at a big company and a big company
looks something like this when you're
looking at systems diagrams this is what
comes up when you google image search
complex diagram but if I if I think
about the domain that I work in and the
and the team that I work in this is very
similar to how our systems are laid out
we are grabbing data we're aggregating
data we're smooshing data together from
all sorts of different systems they're
managed by different teams and even
though that we're the mastering system
where this is where the core item data
is stored we have to work with other
teams and their data so let me tell you
a story that sets up the rest of this
presentation and like any good story we
start with once upon a time so once upon
a time I joined this team was about two
years ago and we had an application that
managed this item data and it had been
live for about six or seven months and
it was rolled out to a subset of users
across the enterprise well while I was
there on that team we discovered that
there were a lot of challenges with this
application so some challenges that we
had was that it was very hard to debug
our UI because as I'm going to show you
it has a very complex UI state machine
when we're managing multiple item items
and data it also has the issue of
dynamic business rules so if I'm editing
let's say a set of Borderlands games
there could be different editions so we
have Borderlands 3 and we have
Borderlands 3 super deluxe edition which
is a real thing you might have
Borderlands 3 digital pre-order edition
each of those has different product
titles and so if I'm managing managing
them together our UI has to make sure
that it understands that there's
differences between between items while
we're managing it that brings up the
idea of - editing modes and this I think
was a unique UX paradigm that I hadn't
really seen before come across before
but we have millions of items
in our store and online that we sell can
you imagine managing those items one at
a time no it's unthinkable so we have
users that come in that can manage up to
200 items at a time so they might be
rolling out new t-shirts for Game of
Thrones and they might want to edit all
you know 60 variations of that t-shirt
all at once and of course they would we
want to enable that but that presents
some unique challenges for our UI so I'm
gonna get into some of these UX
paradigms and I'm going to show some
examples of our UI but they are not
direct examples so because I work for a
big company I can't share much of the
code that I've written but I can share
the patterns and practices that we put
into place and the high-level
architecture of our application so this
is just my mandatory disclaimer have any
of you heard of the term wicked problem
this is a wicked problem I don't mean
wicked and like oh that's wicked that's
we could cool although a lot of problems
are cool to solve no I'm talking about
software design is a wicked problem what
does that mean when you build software
you have to build it once in order to
understand what the problem is so that
you can build it again to actually solve
the problem and I first started this
term in the book code complete if you
have not read this book it's fantastic
it's how to design quality software by
Steve McConnell it's a really good book
but this was a wicked problem we had to
press reset on this application because
it could not meet the demands that we
needed for this product so the
application would fall over after you
tried to manage more than ten items at a
time so what turned out to be the
problem was that we were hitting so many
different api's and doing so many API
requests and it was all happening inside
the client-side browser that as soon as
you got beyond ten items we were issuing
thousands of API requests to different
systems across the enterprise well the
application fell over pretty quickly in
fact it would just crash the page so he
had to hit reset so this past year
we've been rewriting it and react in
graph QL and type script that's what I
going to talk about the easiest way to
show what this application looks like is
to start from the user experience
because I think it'll make it very
apparent what kind of challenges we ran
into so let me just bring this up here
this is a illustration of what our UI
sort of looks like and this is a very
focused thing our UI is a little bit
more sophisticated than this but these
are the core UX patterns of our app so
if I'm editing Borderlands 3 I'm gonna
have multiple attributes that I need to
manage so here's three attributes we
have product title we have street date
when the game is available in stores and
the genres of the game and so we have
three different controls here for three
different attributes we have a textbox
here a date picker and like a list
control so we need to our UI needs to
understand what the differences between
these different attributes and how to
render them but to make it a little bit
more complicated remember that I said we
can manage multiple items at a time so
if I expand one of these attributes I
may actually be I went a little bit too
far I may be editing multiple items at a
time and so here I have the three the
three borderlands games that I'm
managing and the three editions and they
all have different product titles so
here at the summary level we need to
make sure that you can update in Mass
what the product title is if you have
very similar values for that attribute
which we would for the street date so
all the games are going to come out at
the same time but their product titles
differ so now we have to keep track of
both of these attributes in two
different states and we're gonna have
three items underneath it and they're
all going to be in different states but
even more than that we have dynamic
business rules so maybe these items are
in a workflow state of course we're a
big enterprise items go through
workflows and they might be in different
states and that means that different
attributes might be in different states
perhaps they're not editable at a
certain point of time so if the item is
launched already on the website maybe
you you can't edit Street dates so it
becomes read-only but that's not all we
don't place any restrictions on the
types of items you can bring into this
UI if I wanted to bring in a t-shirt and
Borderlands 3l both at once I could do
that and they both might be in different
workflow states so I might have this
concept of mixed editability
where perhaps this item - for this
Borderlands Edition is in a state where
it's editable
whereas for for the other attributes
neither of them none of them are
editable so we need to be able to handle
these complex UI states perfect so we
had to go back to the drawing board
because the way that this application
was originally written we were thinking
to narrowly in terms of how we wanted to
render our UI and what I mean by that is
thinking about item data as just a set
of properties on an object and this is
probably where you would start and this
is how the application started you have
your object that represents your product
and you have these attributes as
properties so that's pretty reasonable
if I'm looking at a product it might
have a product title in the street date
and this presents a problem for the
system that's going to manage this data
this doesn't tell me how I should render
it what rules are associated with it
or anything about its workflow State or
anything like that so this is a consumer
way of thinking this is how our website
might think of an item when it needs to
print stuff to the screen it probably
wants some sort of aggregated object
like this with just the values to
display so we need more than that for
our application so if only there was a
pattern that existed that could describe
data I wonder if someone has come up
with a system like that Oh like a
database schema
we use databases day-to-day and I'm sure
many of you have used databases and if
you're using a relational database
specifically you probably have to define
a schema that schema describes how the
database should treat your data it has
rules around it should it have what's
the max length of that of that data what
data type is it is it a VAR char is it
an N bar chart bubble bar so that gave
us an idea what if we took that same
pattern that we all apply to databases
without even thinking about it and we
apply that same concept to our UI so
that's what we did so we turned it from
having an object that just had simple
properties to an object that had
metadata around each of these different
attributes that could describe to the UI
and tell the UI how it should be
rendered so we describe things like
rules is it required is it read-only if
does it have a min length does it have a
max length what kind of data type is it
what are the actual values that get
displayed and not only that what are the
raw values and what are the
human-friendly values so think about
genres in the database of course we're
gonna store the genres in a row in a
database then they're gonna be the raw
values one two first-person-shooter
cooperative when I display it in the UI
I need those friendly values do you
think that the item mastering system
stores those friendly names of course
not so we have we are in a big
enterprise there's another team that
manages those friendly names so that
would be the you know texana me team or
whatever we need to go to their API and
we need to pass in those John or IDs to
get the friendly names back
that's what are you I was doing just
from the browser and you can imagine how
if I'm managing you know hundreds of
items and they have three genres each
and I'm managing a hundred items that's
300 requests that I have to do to go get
the friendly names and it wasn't
optimized if you got the same genre back
it's not caching it or anything like
that so it's just shooting off network
so we had to describe we chose to
describe our data like this we start out
with the same a similar construct where
the object comes back and it has the
different attributes of this item but
now we're expanding that definition a
little bit now we can show some more
information if I'm someone who's editing
this item data and maybe I'm new to my
job and I don't understand what this
attribute is maybe I need some help text
maybe I need something that can describe
what kind of information I can put in
this field so now we can have a friendly
description more than that we can set up
default rules that get set so maybe
product title by default is required
maybe because it's a text field it has a
min length it has a max length perhaps
it's not read-only initially right
because its initial workflow state
everything might be editable then we
move on to display hints for our UI what
kind of control should I render is it a
single line text is it a multi-line text
because those are two different
semantics is a list type where I can
select multiple values is it a list type
where I can only select one values at a
drop-down is it the toggle is that a yes
or no is it a date is it a date picker
all that kind of stuff then we have the
actual item values so again I'm managing
my three different games the first game
the regular Borderlands 3 there's
nothing special about it so we have the
raw value which is the text that gets
put into the input and then we have the
human value do you think that there
could be a difference between these two
yes so in the database we might be
storing the raw value with like HTML
entities unencoded or unicode characters
but for the human value when we render
it on to our website we might want to
show those characters encoded or in a so
that we don't get like these weird
special characters that get displayed on
on screen so even for text there could
be a difference between Ravalli and
human value and then let's say that
we're editing that second game and it's
in a different workflow state well now I
can set some override rules and I can
say hey guess
what you can't edit product title for
this item so when you're rendering it in
the UI don't render a text box just
render the raw value we can do even more
you scroll down here for a date a date
is totally different than text so it
might have different rules we might have
a min date it's probably reasonable to
make the street date not in the past
right but who owns that information does
the UI own that own that logic not
necessarily what if it was a date that
was the release date and you were you
had to go back and edit it because it
can't it was a game that was already
released but you're just adding it to
the catalog well we don't want to have a
min date then because it could be in the
past so the server and the business
rules are what determine what these
rules get defaulted to so for a date is
the same deal but now here's an example
of the raw date that we're gonna show
that we're gonna store in the database
it's probably going to be an ISO 8601
formatted date but when we bring it to
the UI we want to show a friendly date
and this gives us both options we can
the client doesn't have to care about
formatting the date but if it wanted to
it has the raw one so if a user wanted
to customize their date format they
could do that and again depending on the
business rules we can override for
individual items what that looks like so
this is the concept of a schema driven
UI this schema this schema handles
multiple concerns so it handles all the
rule logic so it ships the default rules
to the client so that the UI understands
how to render something it ships hints
to the UI on how to render stuff and it
also handles both client-side and
server-side validation so these rules
like required Nisour min length or max
length you can imagine that I can write
some react code that makes sure that
after the user enters some text that I
render the right thing or I have a
character counter if there's a min
length or a max length what about other
stuff like min date so that's when the
server comes into play and it says hey
this is a video game this attribute
cannot be in the past therefore I'm
going to set the min date and send it
down to the UI it also handles semantics
and I'll get into more this but
attributes are related to each other if
I have John Rah's and I may I might have
another attribute called primary genre
so they have a relationship between each
other because a primary genre should be
a subset of the genres that are
associated with that item and remember
that we're not just talking about one
item but multiple so the UI has to make
sure that it can manage relationships
between attributes at different levels
so how do we actually build this thing
and this is probably what you're most
interested in I don't want to be
prescriptive so this talk is not about
why you should only use reactor why you
should only use graph QL or why you
should use typescript
you can apply these patterns to any of
the technology stacks that you use we'll
start with the front end because that's
where we started with the UX so in our
previous system there was no state
management system to speak of on the UI
and you should be cringing right now
because that's what we were doing when
we were trying to debug this application
was nigh impossible as soon as the user
started to do anything more complex than
editing a single attribute it was like
impossible to step through and reproduce
issues and so we had tons and tons of
state related bugs well in our new react
to UI were using Redux you don't have to
use Redux but you should use some sort
of state management system because as
you could probably see from that UX you
need something to manage that state then
we have the client-side rule engine so
well like I said one of the goals for
this application was to make sure that
users enter quality data because as soon
as bad data gets on to our website
that's when people start to get a little
upset so since we are the Gateway for
that item data we need to make sure that
we can give people the fastest feedback
loop to make sure that they're entering
the right data so we have a client-side
rule engine then we move on to the
backend this is what does all the heavy
lifting for building that schema out and
we sort of divided it into two distinct
steps so first we need to resolve data
and then we need to build the schema
so what do I mean when I say resolve
data well if you were thinking that all
the item data comes from a single
database the primary data source
you'd be mostly correct probably I would
say 80% correct the other 20% comes from
external data sources across the
enterprise so we are the master data
system for item data but we are not the
master system for different types of
attributes that we may want to collect
because we are the vendor user facing
application we actually collect data
that we don't store and we need to ship
it to these master data systems and so
our graph QL backend abstracts that
entire process and that schema abstracts
that whole process because I'm able to
describe my schema in a generic way the
UI doesn't care where data goes or where
comes from it's all a standardized
contract so what we learned early on was
that we needed to have this caching
layer so remember that I said in order
to show John Rah's in the UI I needed to
go get what those friendly names were
well rather than do you know hundreds of
API requests in real time to get that
data we actually cache a lot of that
data because it doesn't change very
often and since we are using you know
async based infrastructure message based
infrastructure we can actually be
notified when data changes and we can
update our cache so in a little bit more
detail and like I said I can't share
code but I can at least walk through the
different steps that we do to resolve
that data so on the left side we have
our graph QL query and I'm gonna go into
a little bit more about the query
language of Grieco and why we think it's
useful but this should look familiar
because this is the shape of the data
that I just showed you in the response
so in graphic QL you send it the the
fields that you want and you get those
fields back in the same order in the
same representation so I'm gonna get
JSON back in this format but what's kind
of cool is I can say I want a specific
attribute and then I want the values for
only a specific amount of items and you
can see that I'm actually passing query
arguments to the sub field try doing
that an arrest I'm sure you could do
that but what's kind of cool about this
is that it's a it's a it's a language
feature of graph QL it's just supported
out of the box I can do this it allows a
lot of customization so now I've said I
want to get John rows and I want to get
it for these items so first we run our
typical authentication authorization
process can you even hit our API are you
allowed to even hit our API can we even
get data for you okay then we come up
with this default schema what does this
mean so when I joined the team what I
found
and I'm sure you'll find this in many
enterprises is that no one understands
the data that they work with even our
product owner couldn't answer a lot of
questions related to pay for product
title what's the max length I don't know
we need to go check the code the code in
our mainframe system that was probably
written in COBOL we have to go down to
that level to figure out what those
rules are so what we decided to do was
now that we have the schema contract we
could actually just statically describe
all these attributes in one place and so
we chose get why do we choose get so
that our Pio could submit PRS to that
repository and just edit the rules and
we would just ingest those rules into
our you know no sequel database that
would actually be what gets shipped down
to the UI so as soon as you make a
change to the default schema that could
be reflected in the UI in minutes and we
were running into problems where in
order to roll out these new attributes
because we have hundreds of attributes
like I said like I showed you video
games t-shirts they all have different
attributes and we have thousands of
items and thousands and probably dozens
of departments that have different
attributes were rolling out like 100 200
300 attributes it was taking months to
do that and we flipped it to taking
minutes in order to do that as long as
it didn't require anything new in the
schema a different component if it was a
text field we already had that built you
could roll out you could roll out new
attributes and minutes and hours versus
months
so we have this default schema this is
what represents our baseline that we're
gonna ship then in graphic UL you have
this mapping layer and it's it's two
types of mapping so in graph QL you have
these things called resolvers they're
just functions and you have a resolver
for each one of these fields ID default
rules display item ID raw value human
value the ones that are really
interesting are the raw value and the
human value so those are gonna have a
little bit more work associated with
them when I'm at a resolver level in
graph QL I can have access to these
arguments so I know exactly what
attribute I'm trying to get and I know
what items I need to go get them for so
that might result in a database query it
might result in an API request but I
have to do that mapping and so this is
one of the more sophisticated parts of
this process is mapping what these IDs
actually go to as the source of data now
once I have it I have loaded the raw
data probably from our database and I've
also loaded external data for human
value because I need to go get the
display values now we pass this to our
schema engine so we have all the data
available to us now we run rules so what
I mean when I say we run rules is we
have these default rules
he's apply in most cases and then we
apply exception based rules so we might
say for item one we have the genre
first-person shooter its raw values two
so remember this got populated from some
cache and then we decide whether or not
we need to override anything is this
item in a work flow State
does the user have access to this
attribute we have multiple roles in our
system not all of them can edit
everything different roles can edit
different things in fact if you're in a
department you might even have a
business rule that says you can only
edit items in your department for these
attributes so we get very very granular
and what we can do once we run those
rules on the server our business rules
we then poke and prod at the schema and
we change what the overrides are and
then we merge that back and return the
final version of the schema so if I need
to override some rules like I said and
if this workflow state said that this
item
is in state X and now it becomes
read-only so it's no longer required
because if it was required in the UI I
might show a notification that says hey
this is blank please fill it in but now
I know that it's not required so I'm not
going to count it against the user for
not filling it in and besides I'm going
to change how I render it so that it's
read-only so rules like this get run and
they poke and prod at the schema and
we're just making small changes so
remember we have that default schema
that's on the left side this comes
straight from like this whole this
whole part and then for each of the
values we go fill them in and then we
just override one at a time what the
different rules are so there's a lot of
challenges with a system like this it
took us a year to build and so this kind
of system is not easy to build some of
the top challenges that we had were that
business rules need almost all the data
loaded to work with so what you should
do is make sure that you resolve all
that data before you pass it to the
schema engine so that it can run its
business rules remember that in the
query arguments I said I wanted John
Rose but what if John res required
another attribute to load data so you
have to make sure that you understand
the relationships and can load those
human data that display data has to be
cached otherwise you're gonna run into
performance problems so you have to
introduce a caching layer there's no way
around this if you depends on perhaps
your system architectures but in our
case we have you know dozens of api's
that need that need that cache data and
not all attributes have the same
performance profile so what do i mean by
that well maybe primary john Rah's in
order to fill in the values comes from X
API and X API has an SLA and they say we
return stuff and 500 milliseconds or
less but then you have another set of
attributes like I don't know for a
t-shirt it might be a color is it a
black color or whatever fun fact we have
like thousands of colors which is kind
of ridiculous to me but those come from
a different API and they have a
different SLA they might be we have so
much data we can only return in about
two seconds so do I want to group
fetching the genres and the colors
together probably not I probably
split that out so we introduced like a
hierarchy of our data and this is pretty
common in the product space but you can
group like attributes together and you
probably want to group them based on the
performance profile and where they're
coming from so this brings me to like
why why graphic QL why did we go with
graph QL so the primary thing that I
would say what I like about graph QL is
that it's a specification this means
that we don't argue about as much stuff
as we would argue with rest and anyone
who works at a big enterprise can tell
you that not every API is designed the
same no matter how much you want to try
people have their own opinions about how
they design api's and they might be
using gits when they should use a post
or they should be using post when they
should use a put and my god it's it's
ridiculous right
so just remove that argument from the
equation how many of you use prettier
prettier j/s why do you use prettier so
you don't have to fight that's why you
use graph QL so you don't have to fight
at least you can fight about things that
matter not things that don't matter so
this provides predictability I know how
to issue a query to graph QL because
it's well documented
it's a specification I can only do
certain things that provides consistency
I don't care where the data is coming
from I don't care in most cases how it
performs I just care what data I want
and how to query it and that's all self
documenting so that provides safety
because graph QL is statically typed I'm
a big fan of typescript and that's why
we wrote this application in and having
both typescript and graph QL that
provides some awesome safety when you
were dealing with api's more
specifically here's an example of the
static typing so in that data structure
I showed you we might describe part of
it like this in graph QL you declare
your types and it has a fairly simple
type language it's not as robust as
typescript or you know c-sharp or other
statically typed languages but it's
fairly robust and I can describe most
things the exclamation mark means it's
required can't be null and even that is
like a lifesaver if I know that this API
never returns null for this property
then I probably am safe not checking it
and if I'm using typescript I can even I
can even make sure that that happens at
compile time too and there are tools
that actually can translate this into
typescript types for you do you don't
have to keep them in sync you can run it
on an automated basis so I can describe
all the different rendering types in
enum and then for queries you can pass
in arguments to queries you can reach a
Lea spheal don't like the term
description maybe on the client side you
want to rename it to title that's all
features that graphic ale provides and
then at the subfield level like think of
it almost like a sub query you're just
filtering these results so when I want
to give my items I just pass into item
IDs that I want I could get more
sophisticated I could do filtering I
could do skipping I could do taking I
could do paging that kind of thing and
then you can also use directives and
directives are pretty powerful there's
some built-in ones and this example I'm
passing in hydrate true or false
hydrate means go and get the cached data
from the caching layer for like for
human values so the client can decide
whether or not they want to work in a
more optimized fashion where I don't
result in extra latency getting these
human values or they do want to do that
so it's up to the client to decide in
addition you can also do sub queries so
these are technically multiple multiple
resolvers that are being called in a
single graph QL query and the client can
determine like how much stuff they want
to get in a single request so if you
have a rest endpoint usually the pattern
is that one rest endpoint does one thing
and returns one thing as a single
responsibility well you can still divide
your graph QL resolvers into single
responsibilities it's just the client
can say I want to get multiple things
that's pretty reasonable right so you
can do that two other things that I
really like in graph QL versioning
pretty much goes away and that's a
little simplistic to say that
because you have database dependencies
and other API dependencies but in
general because you have this query
language that is pretty robust where you
can implement custom directives what if
you just implemented a directive that
says hey if you're asking for max chars
perhaps use max length instead because
we're deprecating it in January 2019 and
in addition since every single one of
these fields has their own resolvers
that means that each one has a function
which means that you can track who's
calling and requesting this data so I
could say team a team B I see that
you're requesting max chars and your
graph QL queries please switch it then
once that once my metrics say that no
one else is requesting max chars I can
deprecated it safely so with graph QL at
least on the front you have one version
you don't need multiple versions
subscriptions are something that are
pretty awesome that we ironically don't
take advantage of but if I'm updating
item data let's say that I have five
people updating the same set of items if
someone else comes in and makes an
update perhaps I want to notify them
that their data changed and graph QL
support supports subscriptions
out-of-the-box using like a pub sub
mechanism and WebSockets depending on
what you use there are a lot of other
benefits so we're using Apollo server
which is a pretty popular graph QL
server and they provide a lot of things
out of the box to do that caching layer
that I said it sounds fancy all we did
was configure the Apollo Redis caching
provider we give it the the nodes that
we wanted to go and Redis and it just
takes care of everything else
and of course you can modify like the
time to live and stuff like that but you
get the field timing and analytics if
you want to opt into the Apollo engine
it's a graphical interface for
displaying the performance of your
graphic QL queries and you can see it of
individual field level what the
performance of those resolvers are you
don't have to do that that's that's
built using an extension and you can
just use that extension the open source
extension and you know build out the UI
yourself if you want to that deprecated
directive I showed you is an example of
a custom directive you could do
authentication directives you could do
directives that
the shape of the data and these are all
documented things that you can do
because the language specification lets
you and so it's a very extensible
architecture you can do middle where we
have logging middleware that logs heirs
and caches heirs we have timing
middleware that we built that can time
queries to external services so we know
why a graph QL query is taking a longer
time etc consider this is where I admit
that you could totally use rest - I have
nothing necessarily against rest I have
an opinion I really like graph QL but
that's a subjective opinion your opinion
might be that you really like rest and
oh data and that's totally fine like I
said this pattern can be implemented
with whatever technology you want to so
the react UI the react - I takes care of
dynamic rendering it takes care of
undoing and rolling back values I'll
show an example of that and then it
takes care of the relationship behaviors
and it takes care of editing multiple
items at once so for dynamic rendering
here we have our text our text box for
product title right it's a single line
text but then if I have a read-only rule
then that component needs to morph and
only just display the human value not
the raw value the human value for
implementing other types of rules like
perhaps max length if the UI component
sees that max length is a lickle rule I
need to add the character counter and if
we're using material UI this is just a
flag that you could add to the component
so this is totally dynamic as soon as I
remove or set this to no this goes away
so these components have to morph date
pickers are the same way so if it's a
date I need to show a date picker if I
we have specific component types that
might do a date time so this doesn't
have a time component but maybe you have
an attribute that does have a time
component you can either use the same
component reactive component use a
different one it doesn't really matter
as but you can key off the schema to
determine what that is it gets a little
bit more sophisticated with lists so if
I have a list of values for the
attributes maybe it's a multi-select
which means that I can select multiple
values and then that implies that I
should be able to type ahead well what
happens when we type ahead well we have
the schema that we built this entire
infrastructure that is able to code
attributes by ID the UI knows exactly
what attribute I'm trying to edit and it
can just pass in the ID of the attribute
that we're editing and ask graph QL to
go and get the type of head values so if
I start typing an act I might issue a
graph QL query that goes and filters the
options by act and the implementation
could be attribute specific you could
have implementation that gets shared by
90% of the attributes which is what we
do in our case but for very specific
attributes you might do some crazy kind
of business logic we do that too and
since you have all the information
available you can just do it do it in a
generic way so I just showed one level
of customization but in reality our
product has multiple levels of
customization so our schema is a little
bit more complex than what I'm showing
you but we can do stuff like we can
customize at the attribute level that's
that component type that I showed but we
can also group attributes together so
think about product dimensions width
height and depth those are three
distinct attributes but they should
probably be displayed together so we
grouped them together and I can actually
customize the component that gets
rendered for that group so in my UI I
might be showing the textbox for a
single attribute but for a group I might
show like a modal or I might want to
show some custom UI that does some cool
stuff and we can we can do that we can
even go one level up and we can say for
this entire data set for you know
hundreds of attributes I want to have a
customized experience and we did that
too so the past four or five months we
wrote a custom editor for import related
attributes like tariffs collecting
tariff information or answering
questions related to how we import
products I don't know is this is this
made of plant material if it's made
plant material what's the genus what's
the plant name like there are thousands
of questions that we asked been dishes
whenever they're inputting item data
that gets imported it's it's kind of
it's kind of nuts but it's really cool
this schema allows us to do this
customization at whatever level we want
to one of the primary challenges with
the previous application the previous
iteration of this application was that
we would save changes as soon as the
user tapped out of the UI so if I'm
updating product title and I tap out of
it we would issue a save to the backend
server
well that causes problems as you can
imagine because again we have these
dynamic business rules as soon as you
save data it might affect other data in
the interface so for our new UI we allow
the user to confirm what they want so we
actually collect a journal of changes so
using redux we can store different
versions of the state we can store a
change log where we can just replay the
changes if we need to what this allows
us to do is give the user that quick
that quick data entry experience because
in the previous application as soon as
you tabbed out we might have to lock
fields because you can edit other data
while other data was saving and it was
just it was it was basically a nightmare
now in our application we can actually
just collect all the changes people want
to make and because we have this schema
that tells us exactly what the behavior
is between these attributes we can just
do it all on the client side this also
gives us the benefit of doing a batch to
save so we can collect all these changes
together and send them to the server so
I do want to talk a little bit more
about specifically these relationship
semantics so attributes are related to
each other or many of them are so for
this example let's say that the user is
editing product title they make a change
so we have this little blue pending icon
here that denotes that this thing is
waiting to be saved and let's say that
for some odd reason perhaps product
title impacts John row so the server is
not going to know what the new rules are
for this until the value gets saved so
we can just model that in our schema
using basic like array of properties
product title is dependent on genre or
whatever and so we can prevent updates
to that so this is what I'm talking
about we don't have to go back to the
server to do this blocking mechanism we
can just encode that in our schema
that's what it's designed for we can do
more sophisticated things I mentioned
the ability to do like a primary of a
list of values so this one is a
multi-select
this one is a single select these values
are whatever the user has typed in here
now do I want to go back to the server
every single time the user needs to go
add a value here and then have it show
up here no so I want to encode that in
Mar schema and say that primary genre is
a hierarchical relationship to genres
and so the UI understands okay I should
use those values as the as the type of
head values rather than going to the
graphic EQ server we also have the idea
of conditional relationships what if I
picked coop as a genre for borderlands
because you can play with multiple
players how many players for a
first-person shooter
perhaps we don't care about that
question but perhaps for cooperative we
do care about that question so this
attribute only shows up if I've picked
cooperative so our UI needs to know that
so we encode conditional relationships
with attributes so as you can imagine
graph theory and math comes in handy
when you're dealing with all these
relationships I'm not very good at
either of those we have other people in
the team that are good at that I focused
more on the user experience in UI for
handling multiple items we have to
handle mixed edits varied nests and I'll
get into that and payload size these are
some unique challenges I showed you the
example in the in the user experience of
mixed edits so if I bring in four items
to my UI they might be in different
states where only one piece of data is
editable I need to be able to handle
that scenario perhaps two or four you
know all all four of them are editable
we need to be able to handle that that
behavior the other behavior that we need
to handle is when I bring in four items
that have unique values for that
attribute like I showed you if I'm
managing all borderlands games product
title is probably going to be different
between them Street day it's gonna be
all the same so what we say is that
street date is not varied and product
title is buried why is that important
because one of the primary use cases of
our application is for people to come
into the app and just scrub the data and
make sure that it looks okay remember
data quality is one of our primary
concerns for this application so we need
to make sure that people can just scan
the list of data and see like what
varies and what doesn't because these
people that's what they do all day is
they look at this data and they have a
very they're very tuned in to like
product title should never be varied
amongst these items like it's kind of
it's kind of cool when you actually sit
down with them and see how they work
through this so varied Ness was
something important to calculate then we
run into the issue of payload size if
I'm making a hundred changes to a
hundred items and I have 200 array
entries that I need to submit back to
the server we need to do some
deduplication so on the client side we
try to optimize the payload that we send
back to the server so that brings me to
what about saving data itself how does
that actually work because I've talked
about how we get data and how we display
data but like for example optimizing
that payload where's that payload go so
the payload might look something like
this
you might be collecting changes in your
UI and you might say okay for these
three items two of them have one value
the other one has another value then for
street date they all have the same value
okay that's pretty reasonable the users
just tabbing through the fields entering
data we have to send that back up so
first of all we optimize it so you can
see there's not three array entries here
for one per item so we try to optimize
as much as possible like values get
merged and unlike values gets put up
then we need to send it to the server
and the server has to do some work so
what's kind of cool is that we can reuse
almost all the same schema
infrastructure for getting values while
we're doing a save so remember that I've
encoded relationships so I know the
dependencies between attributes so I can
use some depending
see math to figure out what other data I
need to fetch before I can save this
data and then I need to compare the
values and see has the value even
changed okay don't save it if the belly
has changed okay go save it then I run
it through a validation routine and this
could be isolated to you know inside our
back-end but we also have api's that
validate other attributes so we might go
to another API and we might send them
the data that we're trying to change and
they'll tell us yes you can change it no
you can't here's why we need to report
those errors back to the UI then for
ones that are successful we need to
persist them and then we need to publish
those changes so other people around the
enterprise know that we change data this
makes our UI a little interesting
because we need to support a sari
asynchronicity
because we're gonna send this this
payload up and we're not sure when it's
going to come back now but we don't want
to block the user from continuing to
make changes so what we try and do is be
optimistic so we say I'm editing let's
say product title it goes into a state
where it's saving and then once it's
successful it reports back reports back
with a success if it's an error reports
back with an error but that doesn't
block me editing other attributes unless
there's a relationship that says that
but perhaps we don't want to do this
because doing this implies to the user
that they probably can't change it but
maybe it's safe to do that maybe we just
want to collect any of the changes
behind the scenes and ship them silently
so we could do something more akin to
like Google Docs every single time that
you make that you're typing in a Google
Doc you don't see like an indicator
necessarily that's in your face that's
saying that saving stuff it's like a way
up here at the top and it's kind of
silent about it so we can just we can
just timestamp like when people are
updating data so there are several
challenges with this first like I said
if you need data to save the data then
you have to understand those
relationships and luckily we have this
schema that can tell us that then you
need to determine transaction boundaries
if I'm updating 200 items do I want to
fail the entire request for all those
if just one fails probably not and so we
work through how to split up item
updates in transactions so that we can
do that safely but also allow partial
success so the UI needs to handle a
partially successful save then we need
to like I said handle async updates we
want to be as optimistic as possible but
sometimes we can't so if if something
fails to update because they might have
entered some data that fails a business
validation then we want to surface those
exception based Corrections
we don't want to surprise the user if
they entered a value perhaps they want
to try it again if there was a network
failure or something like that so we
just surfaced those exceptions but
otherwise it's mostly silent so we want
to build trust in our application so
when users enter data they're trusting
that that gets saved and so we try to be
optimistic where possible so building
this kind of system is not easy we're
using typescript we're using graphic QL
that provides one level of safety but we
also have over a thousand unit tests for
this application functional tests
building this kind of app what I like to
do like my personal philosophy is that I
want to make it easier for the next
person to work on and so we've tried to
infuse the development team to make sure
that that culture permeates like the way
that we do our software design we're
designing the software because we've had
multiple people roll in and roll off the
team people are onboarding people are
have been there for two years there's
institutional knowledge for like how
this software works it's very important
that when people are refactoring and
making changes that they're confident
that their changes aren't breaking
something existing so we have regression
Suites and all sorts of stuff so this is
kind of the end of the presentation that
was pretty wicked right
both wicked in terms of that's kind of
cool what we built but to be honest it
also is a wicked software problem
because there are things that we would
do differently if we could do it again
what I would say is to do as I say and
not as
not as we did because I've lied to you a
little bit in this presentation I've
presented the ideal state for what we
would have done for this schema driven
architecture but this is the real world
and the real world means that we make
some mistakes so the same is the first
mistake that we made was that we didn't
use the same stack for the front end in
the back end so for the front end we're
using react and graph QL was considered
the front end and for the back end we're
using Java so if we could use the same
stack it would give us a lot of benefits
imagine being able to share a lot of the
code that runs that schema on both the
client and the server but because it's
Java and JavaScript we can't really run
that nicely perhaps in the future with
web assembly maybe we can so we we could
get isomorphic rendering if we were
using and nodejs stack on the back end
too we could share state we could share
code more specifically we could share
that rule engine the core part of our
schema architecture imagine being able
to run 90% of the rules on the client
because there's no reason you can't and
then for the 10% that will requires
special authentication or business data
that gets run on the server so we can
reduce that feedback loop so one of our
primary goals was to make our user
experience better so that users entered
the right data if we could share that
rule engine we could run it on the
server in the client we could get faster
user feedback and there be a lot less
round trips to the server to get that
feedback back to the user we're also not
fully utilizing grasp graph 12 so let me
make a confession the entire like schema
response that we get is actually through
a REST API oh so we're not taking
advantage of of directives we're
basically just using graph QL as a proxy
and I would not recommend that and that
was not a decision that the current team
made that was a decision that was made
before most been doing team members came
on so I'm not placing blame on anyone
it's just what it is if we could we
could utilize more robust queries like I
showed with the sub arguments we could
utilize more custom directives because
we'd have control over that and we could
use more more subscriptions with like
observables because like I said we're
not using subscriptions that would be
really
cool the other thing that would be kind
of neat is we're using just a
traditional relational database and
that's what was historically used and so
they just went with that but if I think
if we could do it again and you ask the
team they would say that we should
explore something more like firebase or
Raven DB or something that provided more
real-time subscriptions to data so with
like firebase or Raven DB you can
actually get notified as soon as
documents get updated and that schema
architecture that you just saw that
lends itself well to a document based
architecture
whereas with traditional relational
database
there's query joins going on for
information that we probably don't need
to do that on so we could get live
updates it would make our UI faster
again improving that feedback cycle we
get more async messaging so that we
could shoot out messages and perhaps we
wouldn't use redux in that case I mean
why why do that when we could maybe just
store the user session in a real-time
database and it's fast enough that we
can just go back and forth to the
database directly so let me let me end
by just mentioning where where could you
start so this sounded interesting and
you're kind of interested in maybe
exploiting it for your business apps the
first thing that you should know is
question do you even need this so I this
is more of a case study of this
application that dealt with hundreds of
data points that all had dynamic
business rules that needed to be
rendered differently that needed to
manage multiple items at a time it's not
likely that many apps are built this way
and so this was a unique solution that
we built for our needs if you think that
you need something like this you don't
have to build it yourself you could see
if JSON schema will do this for you so
with JSON schema it's hey it's a
specification so most of the
decision-making is taken out for you and
there are actually open source
components and libraries that can take a
JSON schema and render it right onto the
screen and one of those ones is built by
Mozilla and it's called react JSON
schema form that's not what we're using
we built the schema ourselves because we
needed to do some unique things so we
roll their own so it's always that that
classic decision do we build it to a
ourselves to do we do we buy in this
case he's an open-source product so I
hope that was interesting I it's been
it's been a really great architecture
that we found in our product we just had
to release the other day where we rolled
out I would say 50 new attributes and
there was only one or two stories in the
backlog for us the front end team to
implement because 99% of the data
structures that were needed with these
new attributes had already been built
so my product owner is very happy with
this architecture we're very happy with
this architecture and perhaps it could
make your labs easier to with your
business apps so thank you so much and
enjoy the rest of your NDC I am here for
questions and I'm also going to bring up
the speaker chat just in case aha
here we go so the first question is when
when did you go too far implementing a
scheme that was more complexity or more
work than needed
whereas simpler more naive solution
would have been better and how do we
avoid going too far well I think I sort
of addressed it at the end but I would
start with simpler and that's what we
did so we didn't just build this thing
from scratch over a year we actually
spent about two sprints doing a
proof-of-concept
so first we decided was graphic ul the
right fit would it work for our needs
would typescript scale well to this kind
of application and so we spent about
four sprints all of us in one room and
we just worked together the front end
and the back end team we're just working
together and we built out the
proof-of-concept so we could actually
prove that a it's saved time that be the
user experience was better and so we
brought it to our director we brought it
to our product owner and that's when we
actually got the green light to build
this thing so that's what I would say
someone just says they like speaker chat
do you guys not Ian's have any questions
No pretty clear that's awesome I wish I
could show code for it but unfortunately
I just can't but yeah thanks and have
their have a good rest of your day